Balaji another important victory for you
against a very tough opponent with the
black pieces and it all started early on
in the opening did you know about this
E5 trap yeah I mean I I saw this
beforehand and because the C4 works okay
it's not I don't like the position too
much for black then you're in trouble
yeah but E5 is a very important move and
already it gets really difficult for him
to play I think absolutely and but he
was still holding on and he was making
some really testing moves
especially at this point it felt like
you're finally putting in the finishing
touches beautiful move Queen to A4 nice
transition and then panic mode hit for
him he has to do something he cannot
exchange on A4
but at this point you had this move
Bishop to D5 did you see I did but what
happened was I saw Bishop F5 and I
thought this should be an easier win
just hitting B1 and like I saw G5 Bishop
G6 and I thought that should be
basically game over but I definitely
completely underestimated how this
counter play came and you missed this
queen yeah Queen three right yeah yeah
this is a very hidden move to see how
far right
Queen 286 and now things are getting
yeah the spicy yeah I think D5 Queen E8
and I thought D6 here was very testing
and I couldn't but he managed to kept
your composure Because by the way if you
don't go Queen to E8 which is the best
move right now then he equalizes it
almost
so he played Queen E8 and finally got
the Rook D5 in at which point were you
certain that finally you put the right
finishing touches I think as soon as you
played Rook D2 first of all Rook D2 just
seemed very suspicious to me because
you're walking right into my Bishop's
like View and so Rotex D5 is like one of
the first things to calculate in that
line and as soon as I saw there's no
attack on my king and lion we played in
the game and c3c2 just comes perfect
timed I thought I saw as soon as I saw
C3 I knew I was winning I think there
well Balaji an important victory for you
congratulations you right now I believe
half a point behind the leader going
into the final one yeah a class about
the strategy for that final round well
of course I'm gonna try to win tomorrow
but it's not gonna be easy at all I'm
playing Mishra and so it's I'll try my
best and whatever happens happens I'm
already happy with the way I managed to
recover and so I'll just try to finish
how I can white pieces against uh one of
the leaders maybe the co-leader going
into the final round that's the best
scenario you could ask for
congratulations we'll see you tomorrow
thank you
have you played against Mishra in the
past is this your going to be your first
meeting
I think we faced quite maybe face like
seven or eight times already what's my
question
yeah how do you do
so far I actually have pretty good score
I think I'm something like plus three
against him
okay all of them are really fighting
games so I wouldn't say it's been like
one-sided okay but uh definitely you
know each other well good luck tomorrow
thank you absolutely yes uh we uh still
looking at the Carissa yet